sur quinze sur europe 1 alors de
retrouver sonia mabrouk et son invité ce
matin le président du sénat gérard
larcher
bienvenue à vous et bonjour gérard
larcher bonjour ce diamant gros dans un
contexte sanitaire toujours un certain
emmanuel macron pourrait relancer la
réforme des retraites en repoussant
l'âge de départ à 64 ans est ce que le
climat est vraiment propice à une telle
réforme
d'abord je pense que c'est une réforme
indispensable si on veut sauver le
système par répartition il ya une
méthode pour ça mais rappelons-nous soit
l'âge soit la baisse des pensions soit
l'augmentation des cotisations
je crois que vous dire la vérité aux
français la méthode c'est une méthode
qui doit faire appel
bien sûr au dialogue social au dialogue
avec le parlement et à une fenêtre qui
s'appelle le projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale à
l'automne
est ce que l'opinion est en état de
d'entendre cela vous savez je viens de
faire un tour par totalement complet
mais quasi complet des régions de france
je peux vous dire que si on dit la
vérité
si on dit les choses 13 milliards
aujourd'hui de déficit sur l'année 2000
verrez à quel prix à quel prix est ce
que vous vous inquiéter puisque vous
avez fait ce tour de france gérard
larcher d'une résurgence du virus
sociale des conflits sociaux dans une
france qu'on décrit comme ont relancé
par le dialogue social ça peut être fait
b un moment faut aussi le courage le
courage de la vérité le courage de la
décision et le sénat a voté la réforme
en 2019 et 2020 dans la diversité de la
majorité sénatoriale 64 ans une
conférence de financement c'est le
dialogue aussi avec les partenaires
sociaux la réalité de la pénibilité de
certains métiers ou techniques
s'il est une question des toutes petites
retraites qui sont une ligne équité
sociale extrêmement forte
donc est-ce qu'il ya ce courage est ce
qu'il ya selon vous c'est très lent sert
de ferment tôt en tous les cas nous on y
est prêt on est prêt un débat et
et c'est assez pardonnez-moi clair pour
nous nous l'avons déjà voté deux années
de suite c'est clair mais ça dépendra
aussi de la situation sanitaire nous
parlions de fractures à l'instant gérard
larcher il en est question dans
l'interview ce matin du président dans
le magazine elle
emmanuel macron déplore je cite une
société qui sera si à lise et se dit
être du côté universaliste voilà pour
les mots est-ce qu'ils l'appliquent en
actes le président écoutez moi je suis
pour le caractère universel de la
république
il faut que les choses soient claires
autour des valeurs de la république
nous venons d'avoir un débat au
parlement à la suite du discours du
numéro des propositions de gouvernement
il ya des signaux qui sont
contradictoires lesquels je vais prendre
un exemple est ce que par exemple un
fermeture que nous proposions une
association qui interdit des réunions au
motif de mixité d'ethnie doras elle est
contraire à cet universalisme
républicain je pense que l'adjectif est
extrêmement important et sorties
scolaires sont pour nous des moments du
temps scolaire donc les signes religieux
ne doivent pas être abordé dans ses
sorties
mêlant scolaire qu'est-ce que vous
associez que les résidents du notaire et
bien l'assemblée nationale vient de
supprimer ce travail du sénat qui se
basait sur la laïcité et l'universalisme
républicain et les abondé contre si les
russes et les contre 6,10 à la réalité
vraie c'est cela et je dois dire que il
en est lui but débat sur faut-il
permettre aux assesseurs de porter des
six débats houleux à l'assemblée
nationale débat houleux
pourtant se rappeler décision de le du
conseil d'état en 2002 sur la neutralité
politique de l'assesseur et bien la
neutralité religieuse c'est parti c'est
de ces mêmes références à tanger pour
attendez vous dit gérard larcher que
cette neutralité religieuse est la même
que la neutralité pelouse
moi je voi est un signe religieux selon
vous quand c'est un signe qui peut être
et doit se dire en plus le faire dans le
bureau de vote de monsieur bardella ce
que ça n'était pas organisé pour une
forme de provocation point
d'interrogation point d'exclamation
qu'est ce que vous auriez fait vous
auriez signé à ce moment là vous auriez
voter vous auriez protester si vous avez
une observation dans le procès verbal
c'est fait pour ça on a des processus
démocratiques processus démocratique y
sont entravées si je puis dire par une
vague de défiance et de désespérance
l'assemblée nationale viennent de lancer
gérard larcher une mission pour lutter
contre l'abstention et senna et vous
qu'est ce que vous proposez pour réduire
cette fracture des os de ses
propositions de rénovation de la vie
politique de la vie publique
avec un principe et d'ailleurs ça a été
assez nette dans ces élections
régionales et départementales
en fait ce qu ils ont porté c'était ce
qui était dans la proximité dans la
réactivité qui avaient répondu au besoin
d'user les médias avis aux raisons
depuis longtemps demain mais histoire de
la proximité
je ne cesse de le répéter la verticalité
du pouvoir ça n'est pas une bonne
manière de gérer la vie mais quotidien
des françaises à venir et des français
ça veut dire que par exemple nos
propositions de décentralisation nous
allons aborder la semaine prochaine où
ces dames au travers de textes faisons 5
lui a changé de nom 3 x 4 d et qui dit
on à donne demain aux collectivités
territoriales par la subsidiarité ça
veut dire celui qui répond le mieux aux
problèmes des gens du terrain eh bien ce
sont les mêmes qu'il faut aller plus
loin vous entendez cette petite musique
gérard larcher qui est celle de dire
bien faut peut-être revenir sur le non
cumul d
mandat pour qu'il y ait une proximité
véritable il faut surtout éviter
on le voit surtout à l'assemblée
nationale cette déconnexion entre
territoires et parlementaires et
décisions nationales des dès 2018 nous
le proposions président de la république
au moment où il avait engagé la révision
constitutionnelle est donc ces princes
sujet tabou c'est un sujet qui avait
déjà été hier on peut revenir seul un
kiosque sur ce n'est pas un sujet des
pandas si on commence à se poser des
interdits
je pense que le lien avec le territoire
c'est une des réponses donc le prix
sénat est une des réponses majeur c'est
aussi la responsabilité des politiques
et des formations politiques de
retrouver ce lien avec le territoire aux
api qui répondra l'afrique à la fracture
démocratique par un débat qui s'ouvre
qui pourrait être ouvert sur le cumul
non cumul des mandats c'est pas le seul
débat a mis d'accord mais si
souvenez-vous mois souvenez vous est-ce
qu'il faut qu'un parlementaire ait un
lien avec une circonscription c'est le
débat entre proportionnelle et système
majoritaire à deux tours
je pense que les citoyens ont besoin de
connaître celles et ceux qui les
représentent très fidèlement avaient
attaché un territoire et et l interdire
cela d'exercer j'ai pas dis 10 une
fonction exécutive en à fond c'est un
débat sur ce lien avec le territoire
c'est consubstantiel regard du sénat
alors autre sujet à droite gérard
larcher tous les regards sont désormais
tournés après ces régionales vers xavier
bertrand valérie pécresse laurent
wauquiez auréolé d'une nette victoire
malgré l'abstention mais il ya aussi
bruno retailleau michel barnier
peut-être david lisnard
est ce qu'il faut ce matin vous le dite
accélérée l'échéancier pour choisir
votre champion en vue de 2022 ou la
vidéo m
c'est d'abord une victoire dimanche dans
les régionales mais aussi dans les
départementales nous allons voir ce
matin le choix de présidents des
départements et il y aura plus de
départements présidés par une présidente
ou un président de la droite dans ce
fief victoire les noms que je viens de
vous citer sont déjà dans la presse
il s'agit cette victoire nous oblige or
pour que nous sortions de la seule
alternative qu'on nous propose et c'est
à dire un duel de deuxième tour entre
emmanuel macron et marine le pen est
bien parce que la droite et le centre
on le voit dans ce pays sont la première
force politique
nous avons la nécessité d'avoir un seul
candidat de lui une équipe pour le
caylar c est ce qu il faut accélérer
c'était ma question l'échéancier pour
choisir leur champion
moi je pars d'un objectif inverse il
nous faut début novembre avoir un
candidat ou une candidate opérationnel
pour conduire la campagne pour proposer
aux françaises et aux français avec une
équipe autour de lui une alternative
autour de nos valeurs nous remontons à
rien qu'à 17 heures pour aller plus vite
sentir dans l'ariège les sites sérieuse
à l'enrayer un bureau politique
je parle de la famille des républicains
la semaine prochaine
jean leonetti à qui j'ai transmis le
travail que j'avais fait autour du
départage nous fera un certain nombre de
propos que vous avez le temps on dirait
que vous attendez d'aller vers la
défaite il y ait d une bronca des
sénateurs permettez-moi pierre charon
qui a tiré la première salve ya une
motion qui a été organisée dans la
foulée parc roger karoutchi contre le
calendrier d'être sans appel qu'est ce
que vous pensez bien entendu puisque
j'ai participé au moins à une partie de
cette région d'où le souhait d'accélérer
la processus je pense que jean leonetti
là bien entendu et qu'il fera la semaine
prochaine je le pense un certain nombre
de propositions mais l'objectif c'est
début novembre
on a un candidat ou une candidate
opérationnel il faut il faut parce qu'il
n'y a pas aujourd'hui quel que soit le
résultat
candidat naturel il est naturel si les
autres ressentent se préparait pas une
procédure de départage je pense qu'en
plus cette procédure elle peut renforcer
le candidat ou la candidate et c'est ce
à quoi nous allons continuer à
travailler
je vais parler de ces systèmes est là
vous
vous dites pas il faut renverser la
table la politique et la tempête et une
guerre de mots
qu'est ce que c'est a gardé la table sur
ses quatre pieds c'est le principe
mon seul objectif est qu on gagne c'est
qu'on l'emportent et qu'on ait qu'un
seul candidat ou une seule connaît assez
bien qu'on soit tous mais comment plaire
mais c'est le présent du sénat quels
arguments quels arguments pour
convaincre xavier bertrand de participer
à ces systèmes dont il ne cesse de dire
qu'il n'en fera pas partie et qu'il ne
s'y résoudra pas écoutés par rencontrer
tout le monde à l'avoir fait encore tout
à fait récemment
je fais confiance au sens des
responsabilités de chacun ils sont
chacune et chacun persuadés qu'il nous
faut qu'un seul candidat sur le candidat
je fais mes options 100 ans et durant
ses seize années d'un du service de
l'état et parce qu'ils ont gagné parce
qu'ils ont gagné de manière assez
exceptionnelle
xavier bertrand c'est l'effondrement du
rassemblement national c'est lrm qui
avaient monté cette stratégie pour
tenter de l'affaiblir laminé valérie
pécresse laurent wauquiez mais aussi
hervé morin eh bien je suis persuadé
aujourd'hui que nous allons pouvoir
dégager et si le candide okeke candidats
continuent de s'imposer dans les
sondages vous allez partant pourra vous
dire moi je suis le candidat naturel je
suis le cias et pour deux jours le match
collectivement que nous aurons parce
qu'on n'est pas car dida naturel parce
qu'on le décrète c'est parce que c'est
partagé par les autres et j'ai envie de
savoir peut-être ceux qui nous écoutent
également mais c'est le prix en du sénat
est ce que vous êtes convaincu que
xavier bertrand va vraiment se plier à
une forme de plus n'avait pas ce n'est
pas le sujet immédiate à s'élever
au-dessus sujet dans le sujet c'est
d'avoir un candidat ou une candidate
opérationnel à l'automne pour nous
permettre d'offrir aux français une
alternative après pardonnez moi c'est
une question de méthode et je fais
confiance à jean leonetti pour proposer
au bureau politique puis aux instances
de la famille c'est nationale un congrès
c'est donc tout ça je pense qu'il ne
faut pas tarder à l'excès ça c'est le
premier point et il faut aussi parler
avec les autres familles politiques du
centre
hervé moral et centriste jean-christophe
lagarde et il lui dit il faut parler
aussi avec les élus du territoire parce
que nous l'avons fait sauf qu on fait
l'élection
qu'est ce que vous allez agir mise à
part parlé à m on agit tous les jours et
fait pas confiance
nous agissons tous les jours nous sommes
sur le terrain et nous avons un rôle est
extraordinaire qui s'appelle plus de 300
mille élus territoriaux
on les a vus à l'oeuvre dans les
élections départementales et régionales
on va conclure le président public
basses extrêmes et peut-être avant le 14
juillet parfois on lit on en tant qu
emmanuel macron pourrait s'exprimer
devant le parlement réuni en congrès
vous l'exclu et écoutez nous n'avons pas
d'information officielle encore faut-il
d'abord ri il s'était engagé à le faire
chaque année et il a oublié pendant
trois ans de faire encore faut-il qu'ils
aient quelque chose à proposer et à dire
ça lui appartient comme décision
je n'ai pas d'informations à ce stade
merci gérard larcher d'avoir été notre
invité ce matin bonne journée à vous
ainsi qu'à nos audits